états unis avec le déplacement à atlanta
en géorgie de joe biden accompagné de la
vice présidente kamala harris il a
plaidé pour changer les règles du sénat
pour deux projets de loi qui visent à
protéger le droit de vote des minorités
un changement de règle pour la
démocratie selon joe biden un an après l
attaque du capitole mais certains
démocrates sont réservés les
explications depuis washington de notre
correspondant thomas bonnin
preuve de l'importance accordée à ce
déplacement joe biden était accompagné
de la vice présidente kamala harris
atlanta en géorgie la maison blanche
veut légiférer sur le processus de vote
objectif affiché celui de garantir
l'accès au vote pour les minorités de
nombreuses lois ont été passées ces
dernières semaines dans des états
notamment républicains pour réduire par
exemple le vote par correspondance ou
encore pour interdire le fait de donner
à boire et à manger aux personnes qui
font la queue devant les bureaux de vote
des mesures considérées par joe biden
comme des obstacles il a prononcé un
discours qui a fait écho à celui qu'il
avait déjà prononcé le 6 janvier dernier
pour le premier anniversaire des
événements au capitole à nouveau il a
vivement critiqué l'attitude de donald
trump mais plus généralement des
républicains notamment lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle où il
avait multiplié les accusations de
fraude électorale écouter et joe biden
la foule violente du 6 janvier 2021
poussé encouragé par un ancien président
vaincu a tenté de gagner par la violence
ce qu'elle avait perdu dans les urnes
pour imposer la volonté de cette foule
pour renverser une élection libre et
juste et pour la première fois de
l'histoire américaine
arrêté le transfert pacifique du pouvoir
ils ont échoué
fr fr ce dossier des droits civiques et
source d'ennuis pour joe biden d'abord
parce que des sénateurs républicains
agite la menace d'une obstruction
parlementaire relançant au passage le
débat sur ce dispositif qui permet à
l'opposition de freiner le processus
législatif aux états unis et d'ailleurs
joe biden s'est dit ce mardi favorable à
un changement des règles au sénat ce qui
risque là encore de provoquer quelques
étincelles au sein du congrès américain
alors joe biden n'a pas l'assurance pour
le moment d'être en mesure de faire
voter ses lois sur les droits civiques
et cela pourrait compliquer encore un
peu plus son mandat lui qui n'a pas non
plus été en mesure de faire voter son
plan d'investissement avec des réformes
sociales et environnementales il
s'agissait de deux promesses
emblématiques lors de la dernière
campagne présidentielle et les
difficultés à les mettre en oeuvre
commence à faire perdre patience à une
partie de son électorat en particulier à
des associations de défense des droits
civiques certaines d'entre elles avaient
annoncé qu'elles allaient boycotter le
discours de joe biden prononcé ce mardi
en géorgie des électeurs dont joe biden
ne peut pas se passer à quelques mois
maintenant des élections de mi mandat